I want to start with laying out a
example cloud native application that
maybe I've architected and I know how to
build it out so let's start with the
front end let's say we'll call this a UI
portion here below that we will say
we've got the BFF or the back end for
front end so this is actually serving
the api's for that UI to kind of serve
up information and so we'll say the UI
accesses the BFF and that in turn is
gonna access will say the Micra service
or the back end layer so in here let's
say back end now obviously for a higher
value services let's say that back end
maybe goes out to something like some
AEI capabilities and in addition maybe a
database so Matt as the expert I'm going
to kind of hand this off to you this is
the application architecture that I want
how do I start migrating this over to a
cloud native approach and and and what
are the DevOps considerations that I
need to take ok so you've already laid
out some of the separation of concerns
you've got a component that is focused
on delivering a user experience which
again can be containerized and packaged
you've then maybe got a back-end for
front-end which is serving UI friendly
api's and abstracting and orchestrating
across a number of back-end so you've
got your three logical points so moving
forward what you typically do is take
this component and start to break it
into a pipeline that will maybe need to
offer some discipline around how do you
build deploying tests so what we
typically do here is we're going to use
DevOps and we're going to create a
pipeline and this pipeline is going to
consist of a number of stages that will
take us through the lifecycle of
building and package this component so
typically the first step is to clone the
code from your source code management
which is typically get or some kind of
get base technology github get lab and
then the first step is to build the app
so build so in this portion when you're
actually building out the application
sure you have considerations for a
node.js app you have things like NPM
Java you have to figure out the build
process for that so the pipeline is kind
of configured to build each one of these
components based on the programming
language advice so typically you have
one pipeline per component and as you
correctly stated if you're building a UI
and it's got react in it you're going to
use a web pack to build the UI
typescript code package that into a form
that will then be package ready for run
so there are steps and again with a
spring app spring boot up your package
it using maven or Gradle and we know
that nodejs you'd use npm and various
other other steps so this part of the
pipeline is about packaging the source
code in the way that it's needed to then
be run right but then typically at this
point the next step is to to run a set
of tests so you run a set of unit tests
against the code you validate code
coverage and then this enables you to
determine whether there are any code
changes that have been made in the
pipeline are valid and again these steps
are scheduled sequentially moving along
and if any one of these fails it'll stop
the build you'll be informed as if as a
developer and then you'll go back and
fix the code or fix the tests so just to
kind of clarify at this level we're
gonna do unit tests or tests within kind
of the app context not really
considering you know inter connections
between the different components yet
today we're not going to cover the
integration story or performance testing
but typically when you're building a
pipeline you need to test the code that
you've written using various techniques
typically you can use test-driven
development which is a concept we use in
the garage so you write the test first
and then create the code to validate
that you can use other frameworks most
of the major programming models have
good test frameworks around them whether
it's Java node or other languages so
next step again one of the key things to
try and drive for is to get to a point
of continuous delivery this is a
continuous integration pipeline but if
you failed
that's going to prevent this package of
code moving into a test environment so
another common technique we use is code
scanning or vulnerability scanning or
security scanning so what we do here is
we're looking for vulnerabilities we're
looking for test coverage we're looking
for quality gates so if your code isn't
a good enough quality both from us code
analysis purpose but perspective we
could actually stop the build and say
we're not gonna move this this
microservice further along the build
process right so if we were you know
building out this let's say the BFF
application was a container based
application running in IKS IBM cloud
kubernetes service I know we actually
have some capabilities to allow you to
test for that scanning right it's the
vulnerability adviser so would that
exist in this phase and so you tested
the code then you yeah I mean again I'm
lumping in one or two different stages
here you can do vulnerability scan you
can do code scan that it's kind of a
common technique to make sure I mean the
good thing about vulnerability scanning
is you're validating there's no security
holes in the docker image all the
container images you build it got it
okay so so now that we've got kind of up
to the scanning phase what's our next
phase where are we going so the next
step is to take the application that we
built and tested and scanned and now
we're gonna build it into an image so we
call it a build image so what this is
doing is using the tools to to package
up the code that we built and put it
inside a container and once we've built
the image we then store that image out
in an image registry with a tagged
version that goes with it right so I
guess I kind of got ahead of that right
there so that's where we would actually
do that vulnerability scanning is once
we've tested the code itself done some
some scanning at that level once we
build the image then you know something
like vulnerability advisories so you
could have that as another stage but
again if the vulnerability is poor then
you could prevent this moving forward
and that will inform the developers to
either upgrade the level of base images
they're using
we'll fix a number of the packages that
they've included in it so basically
every step of the way if anything kind
of fails you're you're kind of notified
of that and you can go back and fix that
right and at the next stage is now you
have an image the next thing is to
deploy it so what we're looking to do is
to take that image and deploy it inside
an open shift manage platform so it will
move the container from the image
registry and deploy it and there's a
number of different techniques for
deployment that's using some developers
are using helm the more modern approach
is looking to use operators so there's a
life cycle around that component when it
gets deployed so and then there's deploy
you know say I have a a kubernetes
environment so we would deploy an
application let's say the BFF
application into that kubernetes
environment right yep okay and I'm
guessing at this phase this is still
part of the developer flow this is would
this be the dev environment that you're
pushing into or the test environment
yeah so typically a continuous
integration flow builds and packages the
code up for development environment when
we talk in a few seconds we'll more talk
a bit more about how we move that
package of code from the container
registry out into a test environment
garnet's
all right here yes so the final step is
to validate the health so what you're
really asking here is is the container
running is it sending back operational
information that you can determine that
it's healthy enough to validate that not
only that the tests of run but actually
it started and it's communicating with
its dependent services and it's going to
operate in the way that you'd expect it
to of course yeah so this is kind of
where you you can connect it up to the
different components and make sure
they're all working together seamlessly
this is where you would probably find
issues with integration or how the teams
are kind of connecting up with each
other API contracts and those kind of
things those issues will start to bubble
up in this space yes and again the
health input is important because you
can hook that into operational tools
like systick and log DNA and
the other monitoring that will give you
a better feel of the current state of
your applications as they work so this
has got as far through the development
cycle the next step is to and again
introduce this is starting to be common
in the industry is to use a technique
called it ops where you would now say
I've got my application I built it I
packaged it I've tested it I've
validated it what I'm now going to do is
update a git repo with the build number
the tagged version and the reference
point to the image registry and then get
ops can then trigger off a deployment of
that image out into a test environment
with all the other components that go
with it and there are a number of get
ops tools out in the market and one of
the ones we use in the garage is our go
CD which allows you to monitor a webhook
of a git repo and then it will pull the
image it will pull the deployment
reference and then package it and deploy
it ready for use in testing so basically
the same quality that developers have
been doing forever with SCMS to manage
you know different versions of their
code now Ops teams are kind of taking
advantage of that same approach to
basically operate operationalize the
deployment of these actual images
containers applications absolutely and
it goes back to a point we made earlier
that this is about discipline and
repeatability
there's no humans hurt in this process
if you go through it and the less humans
touching these steps the better again
one of the things we often do with
clients is we'll work with them and
we'll discover that there's some human
process in the middle and that really
slows down your ability to execute so
it's about automation discipline and
repeatability and if you can get to this
point and prove that this code is good
enough to run in production you can then
start to move towards that that golden
milestone of
delivering continuous delivery right
right so once you've automated all of
those that's when you can truly say you
know you have CI CD yeah that's that's
when you can finally get to that level
okay so honestly mat this was a great
overview of all the concepts we've
discussed already if you've enjoyed this
video or have any
comments be sure to drop a like or a
comment below be sure to subscribe and
stay tuned for more videos like this in
the future